Fans and critics alike have already started
to weigh in on Adam Warlock's looks in the
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" trailer.
Here's how he stacks up to his comic book
counterpart.
The long-awaited debut of the "Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 3" movie trailer has finally
come and has already garnered millions of
YouTube views.
And there are a lot of revealing bits of story
packed into just under two minutes.
There's a strong hint that many of the main
characters will meet a fatal end and the introduction
of Lylla, a fan-favorite character from the
comics.
But the debut of another comic book character
that fans have been waiting for since "Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 2" debuted in 2017 is probably
the biggest reveal.
That character is none other than Adam Warlock,
played by Will Poulter.
"I think I shall call him…Adam."
There's a ton of hype for the film as a whole,
but the chatter around Warlock is particularly positive.
Many fans are eager for the emotional payoff
they've been waiting almost six years for.
What they may not know, however, is that adapting
Warlock from the comics in a way that would
please moviegoers and comic book fans alike
is a tall ask.
Thanks to his many rebirths in the comics,
Adam Warlock has had more costume changes
than even the most seasoned X-Men veteran.
From the brief look we get, it's clear that
Warlock will be wearing his red uniform with
a skull affixed to the collar.
This is the costume he wore after being resurrected
to defeat Thanos and protect half of all life
in the universe from being blinked out of
existence by the Infinity Gauntlet.
It makes sense that the studio would go with
this look since that's also the arc where
he has the most interaction with Nebula, Gamora,
and Drax, all of whom will be returning for
"GotG Volume 3."
So far, the vast majority of fans are in favor
of this choice.
Several Redditors think the makeup has improved
since the last film; and although other commenters
don't see much of a difference at all, they
agree it looks good and fits well with the
sci-fi tone of the film.
But not everyone is as optimistic.
Even though there's a ton of praise for Warlock's
split-second appearance in this appreciation
thread for the trailer, one user said,
But the top comment from Reddit expressing
enthusiasm for Warlock's presence in the trailer
has hundreds of upvotes so far, so it's safe
to assume that the look he'll be sporting
in the MCU will go over well with the majority
of audiences.
Those who have viewed the trailer saw Warlock
for no more than a second, and in that brief
amount of time, all we see is a brief shot
of his face from the shoulders up, as well
as him seemingly punching a downed Nebula
hard in the head.
If you pay close enough attention, you can
see the skull decoration on the movie version
of his suit, albeit it's muted to blend in
rather than standing out prominently as it
does in the comics.
He's also sporting a very powerful soul gem
on his forehead, and it does appear as though
he still has his red cape.
Fans and critics alike are impressed with
how Warlock looks in the trailer.
Prominent movie critic Tessa Smith at Rotten
Tomatoes, in a longer tweet about the overall
impression the trailer made on her, she said,
With the warm reception Warlock has received
so far, it would be a surprise if fans ended
up hating him after seeing him make his big
MCU debut in theaters next year.